they're iconic they're memorable and
they were never meant to happen
sometimes an ingenious onset
improvisation creates a moment that not
even a film's directors and
screenwriters could capture and
unexpectedly cements itself as an
unquestionable classic though they were
never in the script here are a few
memorable movie scenes that just kind of
happened
Caddyshack one of the most popular
comedies in history it isn't hard to
understand why Caddyshack is a classic
especially with the cast that included
Chevy Chase Rodney Dangerfield and Bill
Murray
the film had a chaotic production thanks
to the cast's penchant for constantly
ad-libbing their lines but Murray was
easily the worst offender and what's
become known among fans as the
Cinderella scene Murray as caddy Carl
Spackler fantasizes about life as a
professional golfer and the rest is
comedy history don't you think he's got
a beautiful bedroom dad oh he got all of
that one according to director Harold
Ramis The Improv ran almost 30 minutes
which is something we'd all love to see
in a director's cut unfortunately it'll
probably never happen
I want nothing like it Dazed and
Confused Matthew McConaughey has built
an impressive filmography over the years
but no matter how many awards he wins
he'll never escape the three words he
uttered in 1993
all right it's become one of the
signature lines from Dazed and Confused
and McConaughey improvised it on the
spot
the actor claims to have faced the line
on a live album performance of Roadhouse
blues by the doors I've been listening
to this live Mort live doors out and
there's this in between to the songs
Morton goes all right all right all
right all right the line became a
catchphrase on set and in pop culture
and it's since become one of
McConaughey's signature lines in real
life today I say all right all right all
right all right
Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Man's
Chest the story of Dead Man's Chest
picks up with Jack Sparrow doing battle
with a nefarious dead pirate Davy Jones
and as he's done in every pirates movie
death gave a charming bizarre
performance one scene had Jack parading
around with a jar of dirt mocking Jones
and confusing his fellow crew mates
before filming death ask director Gore
Verbinski if he could improvise and you
don't really say no to Johnny Depp death
began to dance around with the jar while
the cameras rolled and Verbinski caught
the genuinely perplexed reaction of the
other actors but really after so much
time on set with depth
nothing should have been too surprising
Blade Runner Ridley Scott's sci-fi opus
Blade Runner notoriously suffered from a
troubled production which included an
ever-changing script that pushed the
cost of the film ever higher one of the
movies best lines however didn't come
from the screenwriters but actor Rutger
Hauer Roy spends the movie trying
desperately to find a cure for the
design flaw dooming him and his friends
to shorten lives but by the end of the
film he's given up hope as he's slowly
dying he recalls a short list of
incredible things he's seen in his short
life which is partially improvised and
altered by Howard himself from the
original screenplays 30 or so lines
power in Scott
tend to disagree about who added blood
and where but both agree that the film's
most iconic line was 100% pure
on-the-spot power Oh
moments will be lost in time like tears
also not in the script
according to Howard's autobiography was
the entire chase scene which was
originally a fight in a gym and the Dove
that he's holding as he dies both ideas
that Hauer himself introduced to the
story big it's the story of a 12 year
old boy who makes a wish to become a
grown-up against all odds the wish comes
true and the man with a 12 year olds
brain played by Tom Hanks realizes he
has a lot to learn about living an adult
life and one of those things you have to
learn as a man is how to properly eat
unusual food Hanks got caught up in
acting like an oblivious preteen and
improvised the whole thing
director Penny Marshall found in
hilarious and kept the tape in the Final
Cut Full Metal Jacket director Stanley
Kubrick was known for his overwhelmingly
meticulous demands of his actors and his
1987 war drama Full Metal Jacket was no
exception former drill instructor r lee
Ermey joined the production as a
technical advisor at stanley kubrick's
request but once on board he expressed
his interest in the role of drill
sergeant Hartman when Kubrick saw a
video of me insulting a group of
potential actors he cast him as sergeant
Hartman on the spot in a most unusual
move for the controlling Kubrick Ernie
was allowed to improvise most of his own
dialogue in particular the insult that
made the characters so memorable Full
Metal Jacket one critical raids when it
opened especially for Army's performance
he's since gone on to a prestigious
acting career mostly screaming at people
the departed while filming the departed
Jack Nicholson often approached director
Martin Scorsese with ideas about his
character a violent mobster named Frank
Costello in one scene Nicholson totally
surprised co-star Leonardo DiCaprio in
the worst way got something you wanna
ask me Nicholson had proposed the
interaction to Martin Scorsese who
allowed Nicholson to pull a real
script a gun on DiCaprio who reacted
with genuine fear a little because
having an unknown gun waved in your face
is scary but more because Nicholson was
making every effort to be actively
terrifying onset Saving Private Ryan
directed by Steven Spielberg Saving
Private Ryan follows the adventures of
an army squad in search of the title
character during World War two Matt
Damon who had just scored an Oscar
nomination for his performance in Good
Will Hunting was cast for one of the
main roles at one point Ryan tells a
pretty odd story to his squad captain
about catching his brother getting busy
with a questionable girl picture a girl
who just took a nosedive from the ugly
tree and hit every branch company Matt
Damon an Academy award-winning writer
improvised the story the crew thought
Damon had botched it with the weird
meandering story that didn't really have
a point
Spielberg however thought it fit the
character perfectly and kept it in the
movie because who doesn't love a story
about watching your sibling doing the
nasty thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to